at 1 45 in the morning yesterday u.s
marshals arrested a 26-year-old man
outside of supreme court justice brett
kavanaugh's home the young man had
traveled across the country carrying a
gun
ammo pepper spray a knife a crowbar and
zip ties among other tools to help him
murder justice brett kavanaugh and very
possibly his wife and two daughters all
of whom were home at the time of the
incident according to reports the
would-be assassin was angry that the
court might overrule roe v wade which he
learned after a leftist leaked the
opinion
and so he set out to kavanaugh's home
address which he found on the internet
after a leftist group doxed the justice
really scary stuff for our system of
government but at least we can take some
comfort that even the democrats have
urged their supporters to leave the
justices and their families alone right
right oh no wait just kidding they've
been encouraging threats and illegal
demonstrations the whole time
these activists posted a map with the
home addresses of the supreme court
justices is that the kind of thing this
president wants to help your side make
their point look i think the president's
view is that there's a lot of passion a
lot of fear
a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document we obviously want
people's privacy to be respected we want
people to protest peacefully if they
want to to protest that is certainly
what the president's view would be so he
doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the supreme court or outside
someone's private residence
i don't have an official us government
position on where people protest i know
that there's an outrage right now i
guess about
protests that have been peaceful to date
and we certainly continue to encourage
that outside of judges homes and that's
the president's position i want to tell
you kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you
go forward with these awful decisions
you've got to give schumer points for
follow-through the democrats have in
fact unleashed a whirlwind against our
justices against their families against
the separation of powers and against our
entire system of government and you want
to hear the sickest part of it all
do you know what the pro-abortion crowd
did last night
just hours after the armed assassin was
arrested outside the judge's home
the pro-abortion crowd showed up again
for another illegal protest
they marched and they drummed and they
intimidated the justice again while his
children tried to eat their dinner and
go to sleep if at first they didn't
succeed these psychos showed that
they're just gonna try and try and try
again i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from steve robson
says all i'm trying to say to you is the
economy is in a better place than it has
been historically i suppose it is better
than trading puka shells and glass beads
to one another that's true if you look
into history you can find pretty much
anything so maybe our economy is
presently better off than at some point
in history but certainly not most points
in history which is why you might want
to look to protect your entire and your
investments in some really smart ways
that's why you've got to check out alto
ira right now go to altoira dot com
slash michael insider intelligence
estimates that by the end of 2022 the
number of u.s adults who own at least
one cryptocurrency will climb 19
to 33.7 million some surveys show that
as many as 85 of millennial millionaires
own crypto how about you do you own any
bitcoin ethereum cardano or other
cryptocurrency if you don't and you're
not sure where to start you should check
out alto ira alto ira offers alternative
investment opportunities like private
companies crypto funds real estate
venture capital and more alto ira in
particular is a great way to start
investing in trading in crypto with a
tax advantaged retirement account no
commissions no paperwork i'm not great
at this stuff alto makes it so easy i
don't even need to think about it you
can start investing with as little as 10
bucks no set up charges create your
account transfer the funds you can start
investing open an alto crypto ira
account with as little as 10 bucks go to
altoira dot com slash michael
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today alto ira.com
michael
the fact that these leftists showed up
at kavanaugh's house again
just hours after the assassin was foiled
in his plot to kill the justice and
presumably his family too the the
assassin said he wanted it to be a
murder suicide but he's going to go in
there and shoot brett kavanaugh his wife
is right next to him in the bed you
don't think the wife is going to do
something you don't see a world in which
she ends up getting hurt too what about
his two daughters
so thankfully the assassin is foiled and
then the mob shows up again it's illegal
to protest outside of judges houses it
violates federal law and yet law
enforcement does nothing about it
they turn a blind eye to it
and and these leftist mobsters have
absolutely no shame they show up again
it reminds me of that scene in casino
speaking of mobsters
you know that scene in casino where joe
pesci is sitting there and he's talking
to the banker and he says if you don't
get me my money i'm going to go down to
that bank i'm gonna break your effing
skull and then in about five ten years
when i'm getting out of prison you might
be getting out of your coma and you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna crack your f
and skull again
that's what i do i'm stupid i don't care
about you that's what these leftists
sound like
they go oh yeah we're going to send an
assassin to your door and then oh and
then you're going to foil the assassin
because of the two two u.s marshals that
are sitting outside and they're going to
arrest them and and it's not going to
work and kavanagh is going to get to
live another day well you know what
we're going to do we're going to show up
to your door again
that's what we're stupid that's our
business that's what we do
that is their business and they're going
to keep it up they're not going to stop
and they're going to be encouraged by
the people at the very heights of
government and you're going to see some
lip service
paid to how people shouldn't be violent
and no no they should don't do that
don't be naughty
but but maybe show up to their houses
even though it's illegal
and maybe maybe yell some threats just
to put a little pressure and maybe
unleash the whirlwind and maybe quote
maxine waters on all of the conservative
public figures get up in their face and
push back on them and say you're not
welcome here and go to their homes where
their children sleep but no we don't
want violence we don't want threats but
maybe show up outside their little
daughter's window and start screaming
and intimidating them but no but hey
look we wouldn't do that jinsaki is
trying to weasel her way out of this
jinsaki was and this is uh you know not
not at the very moment of the attack
this is just after the the public
backlash against jen saki saying we
don't have a position on where these
unworthy protesters show up no we don't
she's sitting there answering questions
from the audience and a questioner says
hey do you regret that kind of language
that puts the judges into danger and she
says what are you talking about
a week ago after the roe v wade protests
were happening in front of the supreme
court justices houses you said and i
quote um we certainly can continue to
encourage that people protest outside of
judges homes i never said that i'm
quoting from i said peacefully yeah sure
peacefully that's a key word in there
he's fully regardless they're protesting
because they're trying to impact the
results
it's a federal crime to protest outside
of justice's homes to impact the results
so my question is do you regret
encouraging people to protest outside of
justice's homes even if it is peaceful
it still is a federal crime well first
thank you for your question and bring it
forward let me first say because i think
facts matter and facts are important i
never i never encouraged anyone to
protest i encourage them to do engage
peacefully and to do it without violence
without threats and without intimidation
and that's something i said many many
times and i think is vitally important
it is also true that peacefully
protesting in places where it is legal
and is legal in many places in the
country including outside of some places
in the country for sure is something
that is that is allowed every time she's
about to say something the thing she's
about to say she realizes is wrong or
illegal or dishonest and so she tries to
change it i never said that people
should protest the kid goes i'm
literally quoting from you yeah well but
i wanted it to be peaceful
sure that's actually irrelevant to my
question it's illegal to protest
violently or peacefully outside of a
judge's home to affect the results of a
case
well yeah but look i never told people
to protest i told them to well you
literally did i told them to engage
engage
peacefully and look that's legal it's
actually not legal it's explicitly
illegal in the u.s code well no but it's
legal outside of
place some certain places
and anyway and she's just moving the
goal posts
there's nowhere to move them to anywhere
she puts down the goalpost she is wrong
she encouraged people to do a thing
that's illegal to say nothing of immoral
and reckless so she's trying to walk it
back that that isn't going to work cnn
is trying to deflect so cnn realizes
gosh there's this assassin who showed up
yikes maybe our rhetoric was a was a
little hot okay well let's just say that
it's not the democrats it's not the
leftists it's both sides
very little detail at this point kate
other than to say it's a this man is
he's an adult man from california we
don't yet know what the nature of the
threat was we don't know what language
the threat was uh or what kind of weapon
this man might have had uh if he had one
at all because the information at this
point is just so thin
but kate this
this
certainly contributes to this overall
threat landscape we've been talking a
lot about the major concern here with
this abortion ruling from federal
officials and they've been sounding the
alarm alarm on this for about a month is
that supreme court justices will
certainly be you know potentially
targeted by violent extremists who are
angered over this pending ruling that is
poised to strike down roe v wade this is
an extremely passionate issue there are
emotions on both sides federal officials
have made clear over and over they
believe the risk truly comes from both
sides of this abortion debate so
certainly this case
you know really solidifying what federal
officials have been warning about people
are angry
yes the pro-abortion assassin uh who
showed up to brett kavanaugh's home
after he was encouraged to show up to
brett kavanaugh's home by some of the
most prominent democrats in the country
i think the lesson we need to draw is
it's really both sides
it's really
most importantly i think it's not just
one side it's definitely not us it's
both sides how on earth could it
possibly be both sides first of all
the political violence that we have seen
in recent years has been statistically
100 from the left the nearest thing that
they can point to as political violence
was the january 6th the worst of january
6 the worst day ever in history when a
horn hat guy danced around the capital
rotunda
and then they tried to lie about it and
say that the january sixthers
killed cops didn't happen it was
completely made up even the left had to
admit that it was made up
so they can't point to anything else
meanwhile we can point to blm blm killed
dozens of people burned down the country
for eight months at a time we can point
to this assassin here we can point to
that lunatic who almost killed steve
scalise at the congressional baseball
game he was a bernie bro we can go down
the list
at the political violence in this
country aimed at public officials it's
from the left but furthermore why would
the pro-lifers be upset
why would there be violence according to
the leaked opinion we're going to get
what we want we're going to get the
overruling of roe v wade so not only is
the is the violence not coming from both
sides
it is completely incoherent that it
would come from both sides it's coming
from the left and the libs who
encouraged this for months don't want to
claim any responsibility for it
now when you want to take responsibility
not just for your decisions not just for
your actions but for your automobile you
need to go check out
rockauto.com right now go to
rockauto.com
and write knowles in there how did you
hear about spock so they know that we
sent you i had dinner with a friend of
mine the other night and my friend is
very handy he knows how to build things
he's an engineer and he told me he said
michael you know i i'd heard the ad on
the show many times so i went to
rockauto.com and they legitimately are
the greatest source for auto parts for
your car for your truck for whatever
whether you're a pro whether you're a
do-it-yourselfer they've got the best
prices he even said he said you know i'm
very familiar with lots of these
services by far the rock auto catalog is
the easiest to navigate they've got all
the parts so you don't just need to take
my word for it you can take my friend's
word for it too and you can take the
word of the many many customers who have
been served by rockauto.com for more
than 20 years go to rockauto.com right
now get any part that you need for your
car or truck no gimmicks always the
lowest prices write nulls k-w-l-e-s in
their how did you hear about this box so
they know that we sent you
the left has been drumming a specific
line for years now with increasing
volume and intensity and the line is
that the right poses a dangerous violent
insurrectionist terrorist threat to
america nicole wallace on msnbc had the
misfortune of of
promoting that line
just slightly before the leftist
assassin showed up to kavanaugh's house
if mr whitfield's mother was killed by
foreign terrorists the democrats and the
republicans on the committee would be
promising him the moon
what is i mean is it as obvious as it
seems that domestic violent extremists
are an important part of the voting
coalition on the right i mean what is
the structural impediment to pardoning
the homeland against domestic violent
extremism
really awkward timing here because five
seconds after nicole wallace says this
her own side gets caught trying to
murder a supreme court justice a
conservative supreme court justice but
the reason she's saying this is because
she's trying to make a big show out of
the january 6th hearings which nobody
cares about it's like fetch in mean
girls they keep trying to make it happen
it's not going to happen nobody cares
and the more information we learn about
january 6th the less serious it seems
the more farcical it seems
so
she's making this argument
for a reason not because it corresponds
to the facts but for a really basic
political reason
it's because if the left can paint the
right as as violent terrorist
insurrectionist extremists if they can
say that terrorists are an important
part of the coalition of the right then
they can more easily ostracize the right
deprive them of their basic rights us of
our basic rights kick us off of social
media
make it more difficult for us to
participate in the political process and
then they'll gain a little bit more
power
if you just look at the facts the whole
thing is absurd kamala harris raised
money to bail
violent domestic terrorists who actually
committed crimes during blm and were
arrested for it out of prison she posted
a link joe biden staffers did the same
thing maxine waters told her
constituents to push back getting the
faces of republicans in public
chuck schumer we're coming for you
kavanaugh you've unleashed the whirlwind
the list go hillary clinton says you
can't be civil with your political
opponents the list goes on and on and on
and on and the left never acknowledges
that can you think of one example
of people on the right
suggesting anything even remotely close
to what the left has been calling for in
terms of
aggressive intimidating threatening
political engagement
no you can't you can't think of one
example the closest would be january 6
then what did donald trump say be
peaceful protest out in this public
space where it's legal to protest
outside in that public space peacefully
be peaceful so even that the best
example they've got is completely weak
it's all on the left but they do it
they do it so that they can ostracize us
now sometimes sometimes
when people get a little aggressive and
they start protesting
the
law enforcement will actually come in
there i know this is confusing because
for eight months during blm when they
were burning the country down law
enforcement basically stood back because
of the political order to do so
but for instance there was a
pro-abortion protester who showed up
yesterday in front of the president's
motorcade and the secret service did not
let that go on too long before they
tackled her she's gonna get hit by a car
there's this lunatic lady with a
bullhorn
she's screaming at the president's
motorcade but not for long there we go
there are the cops
and they're taking her down and yeah
there is no
there's no giving them space to protest
remember they said that during blm
people need space to express them that
no not not when you're threatening the
democrat president of the united states
then you get taken down to the pavement
in two seconds you see some other people
gathering around trying to form a little
bit of a mob
like you often see when the cops are
arresting criminals yet not this time
you've got cops there you've got secret
service this ain't gonna happen they're
gonna shut it down real real fast
so they can do it it's actually
refreshing
to see law enforcement
able to do their jobs i think they've
always been able to do their jobs but
given the political green light
given the political light to go in and
actually enforce the law because in a
lot of cities you've got
da's you've got
mayors you've got political leaders who
say no police stand down don't do
anything let the criminals do whatever
they want and not here and it's
refreshing because it means oh good we
can have law and order we don't need to
tolerate this political violence except
that the democrats sometimes find it
convenient to allow this to happen and
so they encourage it and they tell the
cops to stand down the other really
interesting thing about this clip who's
threatening biden
it's not a conservative it's not a right
winger it's a left winger it's a far
left winger and i have heard from some
of my friends in washington dc
that the the threats that they are
getting and even the attacks that have
been made on certain democratic
officials
they're not coming from the right
they're coming from the radical left
chuck schumer just a few weeks ago made
the claim that when he was actually
defending protests outside of
kavanaugh's house
he made the claim that there are
protesters out of his outside of his
house frequently three times a week what
he didn't tell you is the protesters are
from the left it's the radical left
that's protesting him
and so when they're when they're going
after the democrats then all of a sudden
we see the need for law enforcement and
and law and order and getting tough on
crime
when they're just disrupting society
creating havoc burning down businesses
then they need space to express
themselves
then they need to
stand back
people don't want this kind of crime
running amok
it's not just the republicans it's not
just the moderates it's the democrats
too really great news out of san
francisco the san francisco district
attorney cheza boudine i'm not sure if
i'm pronouncing that correctly
was just brought up in a recall election
because of how terrible he is on crime
and how awful that city has become
and he was recalled he was successfully
recalled his political career is deader
than disco
he wasn't recalled by republicans
how many republicans are left in san
francisco three
this guy was recalled by democrats by
moderates by centrists
probably by some real true
rock ribbed libs as well
because people don't want to live like
this this can happen it happened in new
york remember this happened in new york
during the giuliani years new york city
is a pretty blue place but it had become
disgusting and filthy and destroyed by
years of democratic
misgovernance and mal administration and
so they elected giuliani in to arrest
the derelicts and the bums and the
criminals and the thugs and the pimps
and the drug dealers and send them
packing and he did that and the city got
a whole lot better
the recall
against chasa boudin
was supported by 61
of san francisco voters according to
early returns not even close how about
the la mayor's race do you know in in la
a kind of sort of republican may become
the mayor of los angeles the place that
i just fled for nashville rick caruso is
a billionaire real estate developer he
is a democrat now before that he was an
independent but for at least a decent
portion of his life he was a republican
rick caruso was running against karen
bass karen bass has been around southern
california a long long time she's a very
prominent congressman she was vetted by
joe biden to potentially be vice
president but she's an actual communist
with actual associations with actual
communist organizations and so biden
picked over her and and went to kamala
harris it's pretty pretty sad when you
lose out to kamala harris so then karen
bass decides to run for mayor you got
carusa versus bass bass should have run
away with this this should have been so
easy for her
in the early returns caruso beat her but
because neither got a majority of the
vote now they're going to head to a
runoff
you might end up with a kind of sort of
maybe type of former republican
mayor in la
that's
that's how bad things have gotten
people want a good society
they want to live in a place where there
is human flourishing i was having this
conversation with a friend yesterday we
were talking about freedom both sides
want freedom
right everybody loves freedom and
everybody accuses the other side of not
wanting freedom
but there are two kinds of freedom that
are in conflict right now in san
francisco in los angeles all around the
country
the one is the licentious perversion of
freedom that says freedom is me doing
whatever i want whenever i want to do it
me shooting up heroin on the street me
stealing stuff from walgreens me
protesting wherever i want to protest
and yelling and screaming and
intimidating people
just pursuing my basest appetites then
there's a there's a higher kind of
freedom a political freedom what the
founding fathers might have called
ordered liberty that where you actually
restrain some of your individual
passions
and you exercise your political freedom
the freedom of the community to say no
more we don't want this we don't want
the drug dealers and the pimps and the
criminals and the thugs we don't want
that we we have the freedom we have the
right to kick that crap out of our
community
that is the freedom that is winning
right now
and i think that is the freedom that
should be winning i think that's a much
higher more noble freedom than the cheap
individual licentiousness that says
freedom is shooting up a needle in my
arm
but regardless of what i think should be
or shouldn't be or the moral arguments
i'm just telling you for a fact that is
the freedom that is winning right now
that is the freedom that people desire
and if candidates want to win their
elections i'm i'm specifically talking
to the republicans who have a real
opportunity here talk to that freedom
cut it out with this you do you
just don't make me pay for it kind of
crap that's not what people want people
are looking at the results of that kind
of silly petty farcical licentiousness
and they realize it's destroyed their
communities and their countries people
want that higher order if you if you run
for office right now on locking up the
thugs and cleaning up the street and
getting the human defecation and needles
and drugs off the street you will win in
a landslide it's happening in san
francisco for goodness sakes
we've got to get back to basics one of
the most basic questions out there
what is a woman
it's the question that has swept the
country i knew this movie was going to
be great i had seen early cuts of it and
walsh absolutely
kills it i mean he is just incredible in
the movie the whole idea was so great
the guy flew to africa to do it so i
knew the movie was going to be a huge
success i'll tell you it has exceeded
even my already very high expectations
for how successful it is this week what
is a woman became the number one most
popular movie at home on rotten tomatoes
it's got a 97 audience score do you know
what the critics score is there isn't
one
there isn't one because the critics
won't even watch it this is the most
watched most talked about movie at home
in the entire country right now
and the critics don't want to talk about
it because they can't answer the
question answer the question if it's
such a joke if it's such a force if it's
such a cheap shot then answer the
question they can't do it
they can't do it and they don't want to
admit that the movie is really great if
the movie were no good the critics would
review it so that they could pan it but
they know that the movie is very high
quality very high production quality
good narrative quality and so they can't
do it so anyway go sign up right now go
to what is a woman.com become a member
watch the film today
we'll be right back with a lot more
there is one political fact that is
giving me some pause for the republican
title wave that's probably going to
happen in november and the fact is
democrats steal elections republicans
have stolen elections too democrats are
better at it and they do it more often
and they're more sophisticated at how
they do it
this is not a crazy conspiracy theory
this is not me with my tinfoil hat
before you kick me off youtube and
social media libs
i'm just reading the news a former u.s
congressman michael ozzie myers who is a
democrat congressman and a just a
democrat political operative all around
this guy was just caught and pled guilty
to fraudulently adding votes for
candidates not a million years ago by
the way pretty recently 2014 2015 2016.
he stuffed ballot boxes so that he could
undermine the will of voters undermine
our sacred democracy and so that he
could get his candidates into office
where did he do it
he did it in pennsylvania
in philadelphia
during 2020 during the election when all
the all the numbers started to change at
a certain point it looked like trump was
going to win and then all the numbers
started to change
i
pointed out i said look i don't know
specifically what's happening here maybe
the election is totally above board i
don't know i don't have the proof in
front of me
all i will tell you is
this has a lot of the hallmarks of
stolen elections one elections are
stolen sometimes two democrats stuff
ballot boxes somewhat regularly
and three philly is one of the places
where they do it
in pennsylvania was a real battleground
here especially because the pennsylvania
election officials completely violated
the state constitution through their use
of widespread mail and ballots so i just
said this thing kind of stinks
and people like even some people on the
right said you're a conspiracy theorist
you're you're coping you're you're wish
casting i said i'm just stating a fact
what are you talking about well here it
is here's your proof
not that we needed it we have countless
examples of democrats stuffing ballot
boxes to win elections by the way the
guy the way that this guy did it myers
was before the ballot drop boxes and the
widespread mail-ins that that occurred
because of covid
this was back in the older days when it
was much harder back in those halcyon
older days of 2016.
this guy myers
admitted that he bribed elections judges
he bribed dominic demuro
an election judge to add votes for his
candidates
including clients who are running for
judge by the way
this happens
there's no way to root this out entirely
and that republicans have stolen
elections sometimes too but you've got
to be aware of it you've got to make
sure that there are safeguards you've
got to make sure that there are ballot
poll watchers you've got to make sure
that election day is not election month
the longer that that time frame is for
people to vote the easier it is to cheat
you've got to make sure that there
aren't a gazillion places for people to
go drop off ballots willy-nilly you got
to make sure that voter harvesting is
not
permitted you've got to make sure that
democrat operatives can't just go to
nursing homes and fill out ballots on
behalf of their preferred candidates and
convince people to sign their names to
and then you drop them off at the box
you've got to institute really really
basic protections the serious
politicians the ones who know what time
it is and are actually doing something
productive
they are honest about how the game is
rigged and not just rigged at the ballot
box rigged more broadly rigged
throughout the system rigged from the
perspective of the media ron desantis
down in florida the media have been
going after his press secretary his
press secretary is a prominent
figure in politics in her own right
she's very popular on twitter and she's
a good pugilist for her boss and for the
conservatives and so the washington post
and all of the liberal outlets are going
after her right now ron desantis was
just asked if he's going to you know
reprimand her if he's going to kick her
off of the team because of all the dirt
that the liberal media have uncovered he
laughs in their face
i am not deterred
by
any smear piece from these legacy media
outlets
the only reason they're attacking her is
because she does a great job and she's
very effective at calling out their
lives and their phony narratives and so
whenever they're smearing somebody you
know that person is over the target and
so they're scared of that i would be
much more concerned with my press
secretary if the washington post was
writing puff pieces about her then i
would think something was wrong so
the thing people just need to understand
with these legacy dc new york outlets is
we don't care what you think anymore
we know you you peddle narratives we
know you lie we know you don't care
about the facts and so you can try to
smear me or anyone in my administration
all you want to all that's going to do
is embolden us to continue moving
forward for the people of florida and so
100 right that's the way you've got to
look at the game this is how i judge
conservatives now
i judge them by how hard the libs are
going after them the harder the libs are
going after them generally with some
exceptions but almost 100 of the time
generally the better that conservative
is
because it means as ron desantis said
that those conservatives are right over
the target
if if the libs want me to stop
supporting a candidate or a staff member
or a political operative they would be
much wiser to just lay off or as
desantis to run puff pieces then i'm
going to be really skeptical of that
person
but they don't the the washington post
the new york times the liberal media
they don't have any credibility
whatsoever and so the more that they put
on their serious face and they clutch
those pearls on their neck and they say
this person is a threat to our sacred
democracy
and they probably were born on january
6th the more they do that the more
likely i am to say oh sounds great cool
when can i vote for that person when can
i vote for desantis press secretary i
don't know what she's running for but i
whatever it is i'm going to vote for it
because the washington post does not
like her
speaking of protecting one's own people
good stuff from dis politically it's
smart of him to do this too loyalty is
very important in politics and it's
really good to show that you're willing
to stand up and not throw your own
people under the bus
very important speaking of protecting
one's own people
the bishops in colorado are standing up
for years it has been a scandal
that catholic bishops have not spoken up
against members of their own flock
who are supporting legal abortion
this is a scandal one because the
because they're violating an
unchangeable church teaching which is
that abortion is intrinsically evil and
never acceptable in any circumstance
but two it's scandalous because if you
believe the catholic faith
then these politicians who are
supporting abortion are putting their
own souls in mortal jeopardy
especially when they receive the
eucharist they're eating their own
damnation if you believe the catholic
faith that's what you believe and so any
good bishop any good priest any good
pastor
should say hey listen you need to repent
of your sins the more you receive the
eucharist in a state of unrepentant
grave mortal sin the more you're damning
your own soul so you
um just even beyond your own political
positions that you make publicly i'm
just speaking to you as a pastor you've
really got to stop this right now you're
harming yourself that's what that's what
a good pastor would do and it's been
a scandal that
the priests and the bishops broadly
don't want to touch it because well then
we're going to have to deal with the
cuomos and the pelosi's and the bidens
yelling at us and it's a political
maelstrom and we just we just don't want
to deal with it
then you had cor di leone up in san
francisco archbishop of san francisco
his name in italian means heart of a
lion and he's got it and he wrote to
pelosi and he said look i've tried to
speak with you about this privately for
a long time
but you're not doing anything
and so you're imperiling your soul and
you're scandalizing the flock and i
can't let you do it i am instructing our
priests
not to give you the eucharist
you cannot receive the eucharist until
you repent and go to confession or
receive absolution for your sins well
now we've got bishops in colorado
who didn't quite go that far
but they they went pretty close
the bishops in colorado have instructed
the catholic legislators who voted for
the recent a pro-abortion bill that
legalized abortions up until the moment
of birth to voluntarily refrain from
receiving holy communion now i i hope
that the bishops go further because what
a lot of these
nominal catholic democrats are going to
do is they're just going to receive the
eucharist anyway and that's bad for them
and it's bad for the religious community
it's bad for the parish
that's what pelosi did in dc she didn't
i don't think had the guts to do it in
san francisco to be rejected for the
eucharist but she did receive in dc
and that is scandalous so i i hope the
bishops go further but this is at least
a step in the right direction good for
them
really good for them that they are
that they are doing this the the letter
from the bishops involves multiple
bishops here and they're saying look you
can't enough is enough the lesson here
is courage is contagious
okay this would have been unthinkable a
few months ago then you got one bishop
in san francisco of all places he writes
this letter all of a sudden now you're
getting multiple bishops in colorado
where else is this going to go we should
be seeing this in new york we certainly
should be seeing this in dc for goodness
sakes the
greatest national scandal of all
that joe biden
continues to he calls himself a devout
catholic he receives the eucharist this
is really scandalous and so i would hope
it's not my call to make but i would
hope that the bishops cardinals
that
that are responsible for joe biden i
hope that they stand up and they do
something about it for biden's own good
but certainly for the good of the flock
not to mention all those unborn babies
speaking of virtue and vice i had to get
to this
i had to get to this i've been meaning
to get to this for days
this is the burger king
pride advertisement
i don't know if you saw it it says time
to be proud and it's a picture of two
whoppers
but the whoppers one of the whoppers has
two top buns holding it together
and the other whopper has two bottom
buns holding it together do you get it
do you get it
so first of all the fact that we're
using these phrases top and bottom adds
a really graphic sexual component that i
don't want to think about when i'm
eating my processed beef at burger king
but
then even beyond that
you're seeing that the buns are not
complementary anymore instead they just
have two of the identical parts of the
bond and this is to say that it's really
good to be
lgbt lmnop whatever
the funny thing about this ad
is that the the ad
i think it sums up what a lot of people
think about the lgbt movement which is
look
maybe it's not the worst thing in the
world if you were given that burger
you'd probably take it and say okay well
whatever it's a little a little weird
but okay
but you would you would know that
something is a little wrong you would
know
that this is not the way the burger is
supposed to be
the advertisement i think is
undercutting the message that it wants
to send it reminds me of klm the dutch
airlines some years ago ran an ad during
pride month and it was these airplane
buckles and the the ribbon on the
buckles was rainbow
and the ad said it doesn't matter who
you click with and one of the belt
buckles had the male and the female so
it's actually how they're referred right
plugs are referred to as male and female
for a reason so it had the male and the
female and then the other one was two
males so just the parts that you're
supposed to click it but they don't
click in anywhere and then the other one
was two females same problem they don't
they don't click in anywhere and the ad
undermined itself because
just by the logic of the airplane seat
belt advertisement
it does matter who you click with you
can actually you can only click with one
type of
seatbelt component
totally under my the messaging is a
little bit
incoherent now
but it just shows you that there's no
logic to this movement there's no reason
to this movement that the reasoning
changes day by day it went from
bor were born this way and sex is
immutable and no one would ever choose
to be born this way to not only a sexual
desire changeable but actually sexual
sex itself is changeable i'm a boy but i
can actually be a woman it went from the
distinction between boys and girls men
and women is so essential that we need
to reorder our sexual ethics
then it became actually boys and girls
are basically the same and boys can be
girls and swim on the swim team and it's
no big deal
no coherence to it
at all
just a vague sense that huh maybe
something here is a little bit off
speaking of sexual ethics on the
heterosexual side nick cannon
who is an actor he
has become infamous in recent years for
making certain black nationalist
comments he's gotten a little more
politically active the other thing he's
really famous for now are infamous for
is having lots and lots of kids nick
cannon just announced his ninth kid
yesterday i think he's got two kids
being born this year by different women
he's got lots and lots of
baby mamas is it baby mamas or babies
mama sort of like attorney general or
attorney's attorneys general i don't
know anyway he's got lots and lots of
babies mama and he shows
no end in sight for for creating all of
these broken homes
he's already got seven kids out there
two more on the way probably many more
to come
the reason i bring up the nick cannon
story
is
obviously his behavior is disordered and
obviously it's selfish and it shows that
our sexual ethics problems in this
country
run a lot deeper than just lgbt which
everyone is talking about right now
there's a
far deeper rot that gets to the very
question of man's role not just in the
bedroom but man's role in society
what it means to be a man what it means
to be a woman like those africans that
matt talked to in his documentary it's
it's more than just dna it's more than
just your genitalia it's more than just
your chromosomes
those tribals that matt spoke to in
kenya to be a woman is to do the roles
of a woman
to be a man is to fulfill the duty of
the man and there's great a great deal
of wisdom in that that we have duties
and obligations and a role in society
and we need to stand up and defend our
families and not just
you know bang any woman that meets
pardon my vulgarity
but the other reason i bring up nick
cannon here
is
for all of those sins for all of that
sexual confusion and immorality
at least he's not killing his kids
at least he's not killing his kids when
we think about
how everyone is obviously on nick
cannon's case here as as they rightly
should be
what he is doing is far far better
far i mean infinitely better than
abortion
which is an option available to him
which is something that's supported by
roughly half the country before that
half of the country goes after nick
cannon maybe they better take a look at
themselves
speaking of sexual ethics being run amok
the methodist
churches i guess their the methodist
church is going to split and so the the
methodist church
has now
brought its first drag queen
pastor
out to lecture
on how god is nothing
so this drag queen pastor
uh
isaac simmons
uh he he's writing poems about how god
is nothing i didn't even want to
copy this text down into my note card so
i just printed out this piece this is in
the spectator i believe
he says god is nothing he calls himself
a drag evangelist he says the bible is
nothing religion is nothing
it says god must be effing nothing if
her boundary-less transubstantiated
bodies of color are run down beaten and
strewn in the streets of america instead
of ruling the runways of life he says
that god is nothing but a drag queen
with a microphone of biblical effing
proportions nothing but if she were she
would be yes queening her her way down
the runways of montreal so this this
nonsense this extremely sacrilegious
blasphemous nonsense
is being preached from the pulpit
by a lunatic who calls himself not only
a woman but a pastor
not sure which is more absurd actually
i'm sure which is more absurd would be
the latter
why
why is this happening
why why does this guy who doesn't
believe anything about christianity who
is in no who
not in even the slightest degree could
possibly be reasonably called a
christian why is he insisting on calling
himself a christian pastor
to destroy christianity
that's why because he hates christianity
and he wants to destroy it he's saying
god is nothing and the bible is nothing
and everything that you know about
christianity is totally wrong and i'm
going to break all the rules
that's what that's why to destroy it
in the name of inclusion
because this is what the libs do
the libs use the word inclusion
to mean destruction
when they say we just we want to make
the definition of marriage more
inclusive what is the effect of that
are more people included
no they just destroy marriage now
marriage doesn't have much of a meaning
and and by the way if you can
if you can take away the essential
component of marriage as it has been
understood for all of human history
everywhere in the world namely the
complementary nature of the sexes the
men and women go together they click
like those two seat belts on klm
airlines if you can take that away then
why are we going to limit marriage to
two people
it's not possible to maintain that
argument that's so arbitrary and
eventually if we follow this illogic to
its illogical conclusion
we're going to end up with with many
more people permitted in the definition
of marriage and then a marriage is going
to be indistinguishable from a town
it's just going to be a lot of people
living near near one another or not
living near one another or nothing it's
going to mean
nothing
they mean destruction when they say we
just need we need to make education more
inclusive what do they mean they mean
they're going to destroy education
they're going to get rid of the good
books and they're going to get rid of
all the things that edify people and
they're going to get rid of all the
standards and they're going to
they're going to destroy education which
is what they've done
we're going to we just want we want
america to be more inclusive what do
they mean by that they mean get rid of
national borders and flood the country
with foreigners so that america is
indistinguishable and so that anything
even resembling a cultural inheritance
goes away
actively not even just goes away because
it's wiped away by the tides of
foreigners with their own customs
but it's actively destroyed when the
left says we want to make such and such
culture more inclusive they mean we're
going to destroy the
the people in your culture that you
exalt the people in your the founding
fathers we're going to destroy them to
make the country more inclusive the the
traditions that you have here the values
that that you have the
the way that you
see yourself the national self-id we're
going to destroy all of that to make it
more
inclusive speaking of inclusion this is
a story happened last week but i did
want to get to it
some lunatic in paris
at the louvre tried to destroy the mona
lisa
and this didn't work
because the mona lisa is is covered in
bulletproof glass
so it'd be very hard to destroy it but
some environmentalist wacko showed up
and smeared cream all over the mona lisa
to protest
the sun monster or something like that
furthermore the story gets even better
this guy who did it dressed up as an old
lady
so he's a trans vandal a trans doll as
it were
he jumped out of a wheelchair attacked
the glass and screamed think of the
earth people are destroying the earth
how how smearing the mona lisa with
cream
would help the earth remains to be seen
but but that was his his argument
something you notice about these attacks
they never attack crappy modern art
these guys these cultural
revolutionaries whether they're
environmentally minded or
sexually minded or some other
other kind of minded
they never attack
modern
ugly
stuff liberal stuff they always attack
beautiful architecture beautiful
buildings old statues
old paintings
high culture they always attack the high
culture
and the cultural patrimony and the
tradition
they never go after the new stuff even
if the new stuff has more monetary value
to it
they never go after that because it's
not really just about the environment
and it's not really just about sex and
it's not really just about
some flag it's not really just about
christopher columbus or george
washington or some guy
it's about
all of tradition
it is about what marx called
the ruthless criticism of all that
exists
we're not we're not just talking about
the new stuff that is being built right
now we're talking
more specifically
about the stuff that our civilization
has lived with for a long time
this is why these attacks matter
the left says why do you care why do you
care
why do you care so much
about
roe v wade why do you care so much about
transgender as drag queen story hour in
schools what do you care so much
about this that or the other thing first
of all i
you guys care the libs care a lot
you seem to care a lot more than we do
that's why the libs have spent all this
time and money trying to put grown men
into the girls bathroom
but why do we care we care even over
things that seem kind of trivial because
we know it's not just about a man
wearing a dress in his own bedroom we
know that this is a broader attack
on
everything on all that exists on reason
on logic on our system of government
what do you care about brett kavanaugh
come on throw him to the wolves why do
you care why during his confirmation
hearings people said this oh come on
he's a bad candidate throw who cares why
do you care to governor desantis about
your press secretary come on just let it
go because we know that if you give
these people the little tiniest part of
your pinky finger they're gonna take
your whole arm that's why we know that
they are ravenous wolves who are going
out there from perches of authority and
and privilege and prestige and saying
we're coming for you brett kavanaugh
we're gonna unleash the whirlwind get up
on them push back in public go where
their children are we know that the
stakes
are so so high we cannot give an inch
i'm michael knowles this the michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show